[Evans] We'll have 1 more quiz about using lists.
It will combine many of the things that we've learned.
After this quiz we'll be ready to build our web crawler.
For this quiz your goal is to define a procedure, named union,
that takes 2 lists as its input.
It should modify the value of the first input list
so when union returns its value is now the union of the 2 input lists.
When we compute a set union,
we want to add all the elements in the second list to the first list,
except if they already exist.
We shouldn't be creating any duplicate elements by adding elements that already exist.
So here are a few examples.
If you start with the variable a, referring to the list 1, 2, 3,
and the variable b, referring to the list 2, 4, 6,
then we call union, passing in a and b.
After the call, the value of a should be the list 1, 2, 3, 4, 6.
We've added the elements of b to a, except we skipped the first element,
the value 2, since 2 already exists in a.
I should mention that union should not modify the value of b.
After the call to union (a, b), the value that b refers to should still be the list 2, 4, 6.
So see if you can define the union procedure as described here.